PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER:
All right.
For this, the penultimate
lecture for ''Financial
Markets,'' I wanted to
talk about nonprofit
and government finance.
So, let me first recall
some of the basic
themes of this course.
Finance is really about
incentivizing people to do
good work, and managing risks.
These issues are not confined to
the private sector, to the
business sector.
They're very deep and central
problems to all people.
The big problem --
I'll put it in the most broad
terms -- just about everything
that we do that's good is
done as part of a team.
It's hard to think
of something that
you alone can do.
And so, the problem with teams
is, that people have their own
individual concerns and
incentives, and doesn't always
yield teamwork.
So, that's what I think finance
is really about.
You might think, I'm wrong,
and some of the greatest
achievements in history were
done by single individuals.
So, I don't know, what
you might think of.
What comes to my mind is, how
about Albert Einstein?
His theories, he was sitting
in a patent office in
Switzerland, and just doodling
on a piece of paper, and came
up with the whole theory
of relativity.
But you see, that would be
a mistake to think that,
because, in fact, he had gotten
a PhD in physics from
the Zurich Polytechnic, which
is a nonprofit organization.
And he relied on journals
of physics.
He could not have done it, if
he didn't read what other
physicists were doing.
And journals were organizations
that had
financing, I assume nonprofit.
But I thought of another
example.
Charles Darwin, the
great physicist --
not physicist, the great
naturalist. People pointed out
that he wasn't affiliated.
He was on his own, he wasn't
part of a university.
I guess, he got financing,
but kind of on his own.
But he couldn't have
written The Origin
of Species by himself.
In fact, he got financing from
private donors for the Beagle.
You know, this two-year voyage
he made around the world,
where he collected specimens
and information.
And actually, he goes back
to his professor.
He had a Professor Henslow at
Cambridge University, who was
a botanist. And Henslow arranged
for Darwin's voyage
and sent him off.
So, these are organizations
that --
I don't think, you can do much
good [addition: without the
support of any organization].
Some people say, well,
how about a poet?
A poet?
Even Homer was a blind poet.
He didn't have anything.
He memorized everything.
He didn't even write it down, he
just memorized everything.
He just sat there and thought.
But even he must have had
financing, because he traveled
around the world of his day
and made his poems known,
otherwise they wouldn't
survive.
Other people learned them.
He must have had financing
for this.
It must've been a business.
So, that's the general theme.
I'm going to talk today --
there's so much to
talk about --
I'm going to try to see, how
much of this I can cover well.
I want to start by talking about
nonprofit organizations.
These are organizations, which
have a purpose stated in their
charter other than
making money.
And then, I want to talk about
government involvement in
for-profits, that for-profit
companies are not completely
clear of a social interest
as well.
Then, I'm going to talk about
government finance of
projects, and then finally,
government social insurance.
I'm hoping, that this lecture
will remind you of things that
you can do, because in all these
sectors there are things
that you can do.
But one of the themes of this
course was, you should have a
purpose in life, and it should
not be making money, per se,
and think of finance as a tool
that you can use to help you
achieve this purpose.
So, that's what I want
to talk about.
Let me start, then,
with nonprofits.
A nonprofit organization, it can
be corporation, that is an
organization set up to for a
charitable cause or a good
cause, and it has no owners, in
the sense that there's no
shareholders.
The profits go back to the
organization for its purposes.
So right now, you're
sitting --
as I mentioned before,
Yale is a nonprofit.
It has no owners.
It's a person, a legal
person in itself.
But it has a board
of directors.
In the United States in 2010,
there were 1.6 million
nonprofits.
It's huge.
The US is probably the country
that has the strongest
nonprofit sector.
My number for the United Kingdom
may be out of date --
it was 120,000.
It's part of the U.S. culture,
that nonprofits are big.
It goes back to the founding
ideas of this country, that we
don't have the government
running everything.
We do things on our own,
on our own initiative.
Of course, it's not just the
U.S. There are nonprofits in
every country.
But that's a lot
of nonprofits.
And they recently accounted
for about 4% of
gross domestic product.
So, OK, it's not huge, but
it's a very important
component of gross domestic
profit [correction: product].
I just want to start by thinking
about nonprofits, and
maybe put the idea in your head
of creating one at some
point in your life,
sooner or later.
I thought, I'd start with some
examples, that are familiar to
me, of nonprofits.
When you're thinking of some
activity or some idea you
have, you can set it up as
for-profit or nonprofit.
And let's just think about,
why you would do that.
So, I'll give you an example.
Peter Tufano --
he's a professor at the Harvard
Business School --
set up a nonprofit on his own,
just as a professor.
I know him.
And he gave it an inspirational
name, Doorways
to Dreams. And it's about
personal finance and about
helping people do
things better in
their personal financing.
So, one of his ideas --
and he raises money for his
foundation to promote it --
one of them is to have an
automatic check-off on the tax
form, so that, when you get a
tax refund, instead of getting
it in cash, it could go right
into U.S. savings bonds to
encourage people to save. This
is based on Behavioral
Finance, and the fact that a
lot of people, especially
lower income people, don't save.
A little nudge like that
would help them save.
Another thing, this sounds like
a strange idea, but this
is the kind of thing he can
pursue on his own genius, as
long as he can raise money
to get them to do it.
He has the idea that
a lot of people
like to play the lottery.
Obviously, they do.
And they just are steady
losers on this.
You know, on average,
they'll always lose.
But given that people want
that, why don't we create
savings plans that pay out
randomly, like winning the
lottery, so that the government
doesn't have any
take in it, it just
encourages saving.
That's a strange, original idea,
which you might find --
I don't know if I defended it
well enough to you -- you
might find it hard to convince
the government to do it, but
he can just do it.
He doesn't have to talk
to the government.
He talks to the individual
banks, and he's gotten some
now to offer this plan.
But what was striking to me is,
he said, when I go into
some company trying to raise
money for my projects, when I
tell them I'm nonprofit, it
changes the whole atmosphere,
because they know that I'm
not profiting from this.
And so, it opens up
opportunities.
I'll give you a second
example.
Dean Karlan here at Yale --
he came here as an assistant
professor.
In 2002, he created
a charity called
Innovations for Poverty Action.
So, this is Dean Karlan.
Some of you may have
taken his course.
Anyone took his course?
Some of you, yes.
Actually, the doorbell rang at
my house here in New Haven,
and a young woman was collecting
money for charity,
and it was his charity.
I was shocked.
He's actually sending people
door to door, at least as part
of his course.
But since then, he's
developed --
again, when it's nonprofit and
it's aimed at alleviating
poverty, he can bring
in lots of money.
So right now, last year, in
2010, the income of his
Innovations for Poverty Action
was $25 million.
And he has a staff of 500 people
all over the world,
operating in a lot of
poor countries.
That's a couple of examples
that are familiar to me,
because they were set up
by friends of mine.
Another example.
This is Bill Drayton.
He set up something called
the Ashoka Foundation.
Ashoka is a Hindi name for --
what is it -- it's a ruler
of India, who advocated
non-violence and philanthropy.
And he went to Yale
Law School, as
well as Harvard College.
So, sort of local here.
But it's been a huge success,
and it encourages sort of
entrepreneurship, or social
entrepreneurs.
But he didn't stay on
as a professor.
He taught at Stanford Law
School, but dropped out,
because he wanted to pursue
his nonprofit.
I'm amazed that these two guys
can be both professors and
running big nonprofit shops
as well, but some
people can do that.
My last example is Wendy Kopp.
I like this example for your
age, because her story starts
with her senior essay.
Do you know this story?
She was an undergraduate at
Princeton, graduated in 1989,
and she had to write a --
maybe they call it
a senior thesis.
And so, she wrote something
about education, that she had
an idea, that often it's hard
for elementary education to
find people who are passionately
committed to
science or mathematics or other
fields, because these
people typically don't
want to devote
their lives to teaching.
But they might devote a couple
years to teaching.
And so, she thought, that it
would be a good idea to get
people, when they graduate from
college, to spend a year
or two in elementary education,
and that it would
be refreshing and good for the
educational system to get
enthusiastic young people, who
are really interested in the
disciplines.
So, that was her
senior thesis.
Now of course, you
can't get the
government to pay for that.
Maybe you could.
It might be hard, because, well,
the teachers union might
not like this, or
they might --
you know, it's sort of
a controversial idea.
Some people would say, someone,
who's taken a course
in mathematics at Yale
University, is really not
qualified to teach young
children, because he or she
didn't take the educational
curriculum.
And that's always going
to be controversial.
But here, where we live in
a society that emphasizes
nonprofits, you don't have to
convince the government.
You convince anybody
to finance this,
and you can do it.
So, right out, she was 21 years
old, she graduated from
Princeton, she raised $2.5
million in her first year to
set up an organization, called
Teach for America.
And the organization merely
recruited young people, who
had just graduated college,
to go into teaching.
So anyway, that's become her
life's work in the 20-plus
years since.
She's heading what
she created.
I like this story, because some
of you are writing senior
essays, right?
And you should consider it
as a model for some --
you might consider it as a model
for some great idea,
that you might have, that you
could carry to the world.
And one way to make it happen
is, if it's that kind of idea,
you just set up a nonprofit
right there.
Actually, I wanted to give
you some other examples.
In New Haven, we have
two major hospitals.
Where did they come from,
and why do we have them?
Well, one of them is called
Yale New Haven.
So, how did that get started?
Well, it was started by a
nonprofit in 1826, called the
General Hospital Society
of Connecticut.
Back then, there weren't many
hospitals, and so, someone set
up a nonprofit to set up a
hospital, and it was then the
only hospital in the state of
Connecticut, and so they
called it State Hospital.
Later, as more hospitals
appeared, it didn't seem good
to call it State Hospital
anymore, so they changed the
name to New Haven Hospital.
That was in 1884.
And then, in 1913, they joined
with another nonprofit called
Yale University, and then later,
they changed their name
to Yale New Haven Hospital.
But it's been a nonprofit
all the time.
There are for-profit hospitals,
but this one was
always a nonprofit.
The other hospital that we
have in New Haven is St.
Raphael's, and that's newer.
It was created in 1907, and the
story is, that a group of
physicians from the New Haven
area thought we needed a
second hospital, and they went
to Sisters of Charity
[addition: Sisters of
Charity of Saint
Elizabeth], which is a --
I don't know much about them,
it's a nunnery, I suppose --
and worked with them to create
a second hospital.
And they chose the name Raphael,
after an archangel
recognized by many faiths, which
means God has healed.
Interesting to think about
this hospital.
So, whose idea was it, and
how did it happen?
Well, apparently the idea wasn't
from the Sisters of
Charity, it was from physicians
who were in New Haven.
So, why did they go to the
Sisters of Charity?
Why didn't they just set up
a for-profit hospital?
They could have bypassed
them completely.
What's the link?
Well, I think that --
I don't know all of their
reasons, but I'm suspecting
the reasons are, that, when you
affiliate with a religious
organization, it gives a sense
of moral mission and social
purpose to the organization,
that it
wouldn't have otherwise.
And it makes it very clear
that it's nonprofit and
encourages people to donate.
So, I think that this
same idea has
dawned on many people.
The people, who see a need for
a new hospital, are probably
not leaders of churches, but
they see a common interest in
pursuing hospitals.
There have been many studies
about for-profit versus
nonprofit hospitals, and who
gives the better care.
I think, that the studies are
generally inconclusive,
because even people, who are
operating for-profit
hospitals, have a social
mission as well.
They have morals.
It's not just churches.
People outside of churches
have morals as well.
And so, the actual distinction
between for-profit and
nonprofit is often somewhat
ambiguous.
Let me move on to the second
point, that I said I was going
to talk about, which is
government involvement in
for-profits.
So, governments exert control
over both nonprofits and
for-profits, and it's often a
difficult distinction between
a government activity and a
private activity, because of
the regulation that governments
impose over
companies and the taxes
they collect.
Let me first make it clear, that
virtually every country
of the world has a substantial
corporate profits tax, and in
that sense governments are
co-owners of corporations,
private corporations.
So, the corporate profits tax is
in effect a sort of partial
nationalization of
all the private
companies in the country.
So, in the U.S., it currently
stands at 35% federal, and up
to 12% state and local,
depending on the state.
So, it's as high as 47% --
it's basically half.
So, you could say that the
U.S. government has
nationalized close to half
of the private sector.
The government is collecting
from their profits, as if they
were a shareholder.
This is state and local.
But it's the same in other
countries, or similar.
Canada, Ottawa collects 16.5%,
and the provinces, up to 16%.
A little bit lower than the
U.S. Japan, the national
government has a 40.6%
profits tax.
Brazil, 34%.
You might think that under the
Lula government, the recent
Lula government, they would be
more left wing, and would have
a higher profits tax,
but they don't.
It's about the same.
China is 25%.
India is 33%.
And I could go on and on.
There's almost no country
that doesn't have it.
So in that sense, everything
is part of the government.
It' about the same all
over the world.
And that's because --
I think there's a reason
for that --
because if you charge too high
a profits tax, then business
will leave your country.
Why do we charge
a profits tax?
Well, I think the corporate
profits tax is justified by
recognizing, that this thing
about for-profit or private
always has its limitations, and
anything that's private is
not completely isolated from
other interests or activities.
I thought, it would be useful
to think of one example.
There's a company
called TEPCO.
You heard of this company?
I don't expect that you would.
It's the fourth largest electric
power company in the
world, and it's traded in the
U.S. And you may own shares in
it and not know it, because
it's such a big
and important company.
Or at least your parents, good
chance that they own shares in
it, because they probably own
some diversified portfolio in
their pension plan, or maybe
they even have it set up in a
trust for you already.
So, don't judge TEPCO
too harshly.
All right.
But let me just tell you about
your investment in TEPCO.
Guess what country it's in?
STUDENT: Japan.
PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER:
You got it.
So, somebody knows.
Why would that matter
right now?
Big electric power
company in Japan.
That sounds like a
great investment?
Yes?
STUDENT: They own the power
plant has been affected by the
earthquake in Japan.
PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER:
That's right.
They own particularly the
Fukushima power plant.
So, I checked out this morning,
what the share price
is going for in TEPCO.
So it was, as of a month
or so ago, $25 a share.
And it's down to $5 a share.
It just went [SOUND EFFECT
INDICATING DOWNWARD MOVEMENT],
and you know exactly why.
So, I looked at this further.
J.P. Morgan estimates now, that
claims against TEPCO will
be $25 billion, or a couple
of trillion yen.
But that's not all.
They're also damaged, right?
Everything's in ruins.
So, some people are predicting
that TEPCO will go bankrupt.
So, they've created this whole
mess in Japan, and they're
just going to go bankrupt, and
we have limited liability.
They're not going to
come after you.
The Japanese government could do
diligence and find out that
you own shares in TEPCO, and
TEPCO was negligent.
They messed up.
They didn't do their safety
procedures well enough.
But they'll never
go after you.
This is the whole idea
of limited liability.
So many people all over the
world are owning shares, and
we can't expect them to be
responsible for -- you can't
inspect the Fukushima plant,
even though you may be a
beneficiary of its profits.
So, that's why they collect
the corporate profits --
Japan is collecting 40% percent
corporate profits tax,
and that can be used to offset
the damages that the Japanese
government now has to pay for.
So, it all seems right.
There's a plan here.
So, you wonder, is TEPCO
private or not?
Well, it is private in the
sense that there are
shareholders and there are
profits, but it's regulated by
Japan, it's taxed by
Japan, and Japan
pays for their mistakes.
So, that's typical.
I'll give you another
example from this
country, General Motors.
General Motors was the biggest
car company in the United
States, and then, it had a
little problem during the
financial crisis and had
to file for Chapter 11
bankruptcy.
What am I referring to,
when I say Chapter 11?
The Bankruptcy Act has chapters,
and each chapter
says something different.
The two most important chapters
for companies are
Chapter 7 and Chapter 11.
What the bankruptcy law does is,
it creates a framework for
dealing with insolvency.
And the framework says, that a
company that is in trouble can
choose to apply for bankruptcy,
and there's
basically two important
ways to do that.
Chapter 7 details one way you
can apply for bankruptcy, and
Chapter 11 details
another way.
Chapter 7 is liquidation.
That means, that the company is
in such trouble, that we're
going to shut it down and
sell off all the assets.
Chapter 11 is for a company
that is in trouble, but
there's something worth
salvaging in terms of
operating, continuing
the business.
So, GM chose Chapter
11 bankruptcy.
They thought, obviously we've
been making cars for now close
to 100 years --
well, at least the companies
that went
together to form GM --
and we have a big future.
So, we can't pay our bills now,
but we should continue.
So, they filed for Chapter
11 bankruptcy.
But they were in such trouble,
that they couldn't get out of
it, so the U.S. government and
the Canadian government
invested in GM.
What happened was,
General Motors --
they changed the name in
the most subtle way.
The official name of the company
was General Motors
Corporation.
When they filed for Chapter 11
bankruptcy, the shareholders
were wiped out --
nobody got executed --
you lost all your money.
And so, if you find in your
attic some nice, beautiful
share certificates for General
Motors Corporation, you can
just use them as wallpaper
or whatever.
They're worthless.
But if it's different, if it
says General Motors Company,
because that refers
to the new GM --
they wanted to change the name,
but they didn't really
want to change the name.
They had to change the name,
so that people wouldn't
confuse the two.
So, what happened?
How did we get a new GM?
Well, the new GM was owned
by the U.S. government.
It was equal to --
where is it, I had it here --
60.8% U.S., Canada owned 12%.
The UAW, United Auto
Workers, got 17.5%.
Why did the union, by the
way, get 17% of GM?
Well, I don't know the whole
story, but I'm sure it has
something to do with
GM's obligations.
Maybe they failed
on something, I
don't know the details.
But it seemed, in the bankruptcy
proceedings, that
the implicit debts, that the
company owed to their workers,
would be represented by a
share in the company.
And then, the rest went to the
bondholders, people, who own
debt, not equity, who own debt
in GM, got the remaining
share, and they also got
warrants, which are options to
buy more shares, which will
dilute down the U.S. and
Canada and UAW shares.
So, that's the settlement.
The result of the settlement
was, that it was a government
owned organization.
Now, they've just done an IPO,
so they're reversing this
ownership structure.
But the point is, that companies
that look private
may end up government
eventually, one time or another.
So, companies have to kind of
think of themselves as, even
in an arch-capitalist country
like the United States, as
partly government
organizations.
By the way, there's something
else called personal
bankruptcy.
And personal bankruptcy is
another involvement of the
government in risk management.
You as an individual can declare
bankruptcy, and you
can choose these chapters or
you can do -- there's other
provisions as well.
But you can use Chapter 7 to
wipe out all of your debts.
The new bankruptcy law that
Congress passed a few years
ago tends to limit your
ability to do that.
But within limits, the same
government is kind of a
shareholder, just as
individuals are.
I mean, a shareholder in
individuals' lifetime incomes.
I guess, what I'm saying is,
that the whole idea of public
versus private is a
complicated one.
And what seems public
at one time will
seem private at another.
The behavior of nonprofits is
not strikingly different than
the behavior of for-profits.
So, I found a statistic, that
42% of nonprofits pay bonuses
to their executives.
That is, they're using the same
kind of incentive plans
that private corporations do.
Why would they do that?
Well, they do that, because they
have to hire people, and
people in the for-profit sector
are getting bonuses.
So, how do you hire someone, and
get someone good, unless
you pay the bonus as well?
The government faces a big
problem, in that the public is
very sensitive to paying high
salaries to government
employees, because they
think it's unfair.
Why should some government
bureaucrat be
paid more than I get?
As a result, they have trouble
hiring good people.
But in the nonprofit sector --
the nonprofit sector is
not constrained --
well, they have some
constraints over --
they're regulated to prevent
them from stealing the money.
I think, part of the idea
of having nonprofits --
this is a general point -- is,
that the government is kind of
confined to politically correct,
conventional wisdom
type activities.
And they can do things that
are just generally
acknowledged by the average
person as a good thing, but
they can't do something
innovative as well or
controversial as well.
And I think, that it's often in
those controversial things,
that some of our biggest
progress is made.
So, I gave the example of
Charles Darwin and his
professor, who advocated his
voyage around the world.
Professor --
I'm trying to see what
his name was --
Henslow, I think it was,
was actually a --
John Stevens Henslow, a botanist
but also a advocate
of natural theology.
And he sent Darwin out on this
voyage, because he thought,
that studying nature enabled
you to discover God.
Little did he know, Darwin would
end up an atheist after
his voyage.
But it's this kind of weird
stuff that gets financed.
Or Wendy Kopp, I gave as another
example, whose ideas
were too controversial.
I mean, the idea of sending
someone out, who didn't have
an education diploma to teach,
too controversial.
So, I think that there is maybe
a growing recognition of
the importance of having
people who are --
well, there's a term --
social entrepreneurs.
I don't know, whether they're
for-profit or nonprofit, but
they're people, who do things
out of a sense of mission,
beyond making money, but
helping the world.
And you see this reported in
newspapers and magazines, that
the 21st century seems to be a
century, where there's more
and more of this
kind of thing.
And it's in substantial measure,
I think, nonprofit.
Now, I wanted to move to the
third thing, which I said is
municipal, or state
and local finance.
It's a big topic, but an awful
lot of what gets done in this
country is done by state
and local governments.
It's something on the order --
it's bigger than the
federal government.
The state and local governments
spend about twice
as much money as the U.S.
federal government.
They run all the public schools,
fire departments,
police departments,
most of the parks.
What else?
I mean, a lot of things are
being run by state and local
governments.
I think, another thing that one
could do to make things
happen in the world --
I mentioned the possibility
of setting up a nonprofit.
You can make things happen by
doing that, but you can also
make things happen by
approaching a local
government, and saying to them,
I think that you would
do well to build a hospital, or
build a bridge, or build a
new school, or even kind of
business oriented things, that
would be projects that the
government can undertake.
And then, they can finance
it as a state and local
government.
Now one thing, in the United
States, every state in the
United States has a ''balanced
budget rule.'' That is, they
have to tax people for all of
the expenditures they make.
They are not allowed
to go into debt.
But we have to be careful about
what the balanced budget
rules in their constitution say,
because, obviously, there
is municipal debt.
Governments do borrow money.
State and local governments
in the United States have
typically --
it differs across
states -- they
typically have two budgets.
They have an operating budget
and a capital budget.
The operating budget is what has
to be balanced, according
to their constitutions.
The operating budget involves a
list of all the expenditures
they made for operations,
and the taxes.
And they cannot --
it differs by state on how it's
worded -- but they cannot
plan to run a deficit
in some states.
Or if they do run a deficit on
the operating budget, they
have to correct it soon
and have a plan for
correcting it soon.
But the capital budget
is different.
If a city builds a new school,
for example, that's not an
operating expense.
It's a capital expense.
So, it's building something
that will last through the
ages, and so it goes on the
capital budget, and not on the
operating budget.
And all the states allow this.
They can raise money by
borrowing, and they
routinely do that.
So, that means they get into
debt, and then they have a
potential for going
bankrupt as well.
So, this is the way it works.
Imagine that you're setting
up a new town, and
it's small right now.
Little town, but we know, that
people are coming this way,
and it's going to be a big
town in 20, 30 years.
So, what do we do?
Well, you lay out the streets,
and you plan for a
big town right now.
You better plan for it or
it'll get congested.
So, better lay out wide
enough streets.
That's easy to do.
But you want to build the
streets, before the people
come, have the layout,
and have lots,
and have it all planned.
And how about a sewage system?
The people aren't here yet.
So, you consult a sewage
engineer, and the engineer
tells you, you know, if you're
going to build a sewage
system, you should do
it all at once.
It's going to be too expensive
to do it year after year, just
adding a little bit,
a little bit.
You've got to have a plan,
have an idea, where
this city is going.
Let's build it for a city
of 20,000 people.
We can do it now, but it will
cost you $100 million.
So, what do you do?
You might say, we can't
pay for that.
There's only 30 people
living in this town.
How do we come up with
$100 million?
Obviously, you borrow.
You put it on the
capital budget.
And that is fair and just,
because then, as people come
to the city, they will
then pay taxes and
pay back the debt.
This is the way it works,
and it's the
way it's always worked.
Now, you could say, well, no,
it shouldn't be this way.
Why don't we have all of the
individual people pay for
their own sewers, and add to the
sewer system as they build
their houses.
It's not going to work.
That would be crazy.
You've got to build the whole
system in advance, and so
that's what city governments
do routinely.
And they go deeply into debt as
a result of having created
all of these capital
investments, and having the
debt against them.
So, your city that has 20
people has borrowed $100
million, and it's going
to be a city of
20,000 people, you think.
What if it doesn't work?
What if they don't come?
Your plan was wrong.
Then, the city is at risk of
going bankrupt, right?
So, there's another whole
chapter for municipal
bankruptcy, Chapter 9 of
the Bankruptcy Code.
And Chapter 9 is for
city government.
There's a problem, that cities
going bankrupt are different,
because they don't have
any shareholders.
They do have an ability
to tax people.
There's a question of how much
you should tax people in a
bankrupt city.
If you get tax them too much,
they'll just all leave. So,
it's a subtle problem.
But fortunately, there haven't
been, and I'm not sure we
really understand why, there
have not been many municipal
bankruptcies at all.
Between 1975 --
OK, I'm sorry.
Do I have data?
I thought I had data on numbers
of bankruptcy --
There are some famous municipal
bankruptcies.
New York City went bankrupt,
or it was about to declare
bankruptcy in the 1970s, but
it was saved by bailouts.
Maybe, that's the reason
why we don't.
Basically, when New York City
said, that it couldn't pay its
debts, the State of New York
came by with a bailout.
And then also, although
reluctantly and with a lag,
the U.S. federal government
came in with a bailout.
So, New York never declared
bankruptcy.
A lot of cities will have what's
called a ''rainy day
fund.'' So, they will accumulate
assets to help them
over troubled times.
So, you can collect somewhat
higher taxes, and then, you
have an endowment, the city has
an endowment, which can
help tide them over through
difficult times.
But recently, most
of the rainy day
funds have been exhausted.
The state and local governments
saved for a rainy
day, and this was a rainy day,
this financial crisis.
And so, most state and local
governments are in trouble
right now, because of the
recession causing their tax
revenues to decline, and there's
increasing worry about
municipal bankruptcies.
So, I said that there haven't
been many historically, but
people are edgy now thinking,
that there could be some now
because of the financial
crisis.
And so, the yields on municipal
bonds have gone up.
Municipal bonds are tax-free
in the United States.
[clarification: Predominantly,
municipal bonds are tax-free
in the U.S., but there are a few
exceptions, as outlined in
the Fabozzi et al. textbook.]
So, if the City of New Haven
issues debt, and you buy that
debt, you are not subject to
federal income tax on the
interest that you earn.
That's because in the
constitution it says, that
there's a separation between
federal and state.
The federal cannot tax the
state, so they don't tax your
municipal bond.
There's a subsidy towards
municipal bonds implicit in
the tax law.
By the way, let me just
mention the fact, that
municipal bonds issued by local
governments are not
subject to taxes, extends, as
well, to Yale University.
So, Yale University issues
bonds, that are in the same
category as municipal bonds,
and they're not taxed.
So, there's an advantage, a tax
advantage, and especially
higher-income investors like to
invest in municipal bonds,
because it matters more for
higher income investors,
because the tax rate hits them
more, so there's an advantage.
So, Yale issues municipal
bonds, and Yale is an
important debtor.
Now, you might wonder
about that.
So, let's talk about Yale as
a municipal bond issuer.
Yale has an endowment of $16
billion as of last year
[addition: 2010],
and it has a debt
of $2.5 billion.
So, that leaves Yale with
only $13.5 billion in
assets after debt.
So, you might say, why does
Yale borrow money?
Right?
I mean, it's got $16 billion
in investing.
Why is it borrowing?
Well, there are many reasons,
I suppose, but the immediate
and obvious reason that comes to
mind is, that Yale borrows
money, because it can borrow
at a tax-subsidized rate.
If Yale's debt is not subject
to income tax, then that
means, it can borrow at a lower
rate, and Yale would be
inclined --
or any nonprofit that can issue
non-taxable debt --
would like to do that, in order
to invest in assets that
are taxable.
Yale doesn't pay any taxes
on either of them.
So you see, what I'm saying?
Municipal debt has a lower yield
in the market, because
everybody knows, it's not
subject to income taxes, so it
has a low yield.
So, Yale could issue that debt,
and use the money to
invest in high yielding things
that are taxable, and it's not
going to pay taxes
on them, either.
So, there's an arbitrage game
that Yale could play, or any
nonprofits could play, but it
does not, because it's not
allowed to, unless it's using
the proceeds of the debt for
appropriate causes.
You have to understand, this is
why Yale University has a
substantial debt, and why the
City of New Haven has a
substantial debt.
It all makes sense in some
basic finance framework.
But there's a lot of concern
about indebtedness right now,
because, with the financial
crisis, the U.S. and Europe
and many other countries
are suffering debt
crises right now.
So, it's renewing calls for a
balanced budget amendment.
The U.S. government does not
have a balanced budget
amendment, like the state
governments do.
And in fact, the
U.S. government
has only one budget.
It does not have a
capital budget.
So in some sense, the state
governments are more
sophisticated than the federal
government in the U.S., in
that they have the distinction
between
operating and capital budgets.
I guess the reason,
why the U.S. --
the U.S. government has
considered adopting a capital
budget, but it has
never done so.
I think, maybe, it's because the
U.S. government has fewer
investments, like schools or
parks or water facilities,
sewage facilities.
It doesn't do that kind of
thing, so it doesn't have as
many clearly capital projects.
It has a much bigger debt
than the state and local
governments.
I guess, then, I'll move to my
last topic today, which is
about government social
insurance.
And this is along the same
theme, I'm talking today about
the roles of --
finance is about risk
management, and it's about
incentivization.
And some of the basic rules
are classified under the
rubric of social insurance,
which is offered by the
government.
This is a huge topic.
Social insurance refers to
insurance, that is not
available by a private insurance
company, but that is
offered generally by
governments, and let me just
give some examples.
I put it first, progressive
taxes.
Progressive taxes are income
taxes that tax higher income
people at a lower rate
[correction: at a higher rate].
And progressive taxes have
increasingly, in recent years,
adopted something analogous to
the earned income tax credit,
the EITC --
that's the U.S. name for it, but
it's now in many countries
around the world --
that provides negative taxes for
the lowest income people.
So, the effect of progressive
taxes with earned income tax
credit is to insulate
people somewhat from
shocks to their income.
They call it an earned income
tax credit, by the way,
because you have to have earned
income to get the credit.
You can't be just unemployed.
But if you are working and
earning very little,
especially if you have a
family, then you have a
negative income tax rate, so
that the government augments
your low income with
a negative tax.
I think this is very
important, and
it actually is effective.
Otherwise, the world
would be much more
unequal than it is now.
I would add, by the way, public
services, which are
offered out of taxes,
to everyone in a
country, notably education.
School systems are generally
free and that is, again,
something that--
I consider these a form of
insurance, because they
benefit people, who are
unsuccessful in earning money.
So, it's like an insurance
program against possible
failure in achieving status
in the economic system.
So, we also have --
I'll go up here --
three, Social Security.
And I'm using U.S. terms, but
these are terms that --
these things happen
in virtually
all advanced countries.
In the U.S., we call it OASDI.
That stands for Old
Age, Survivors,
and Disability Insurance.
Old age insurance is pensions,
and that's the biggest part of
the social security system
in the United States.
It's insuring --
well, it's really something you
know is going to happen --
you're going to get
old someday,
but we call it insurance.
Survivors insurance
is life insurance.
I mean, it benefits you.
You're getting too old for this
now, but if your parents
die when you're young,
the U.S. government
will give you an income.
You're an orphan, you have
nothing, your parents died,
and left you nothing, you
get survivors insurance.
You didn't know you
had this, right?
It's not publicized a lot, but
it's part of what protects
people, and it's offered
by the government.
And then thirdly, disability
insurance --
again, offered by the
government --
is against you breaking your
neck and becoming paralyzed.
Or anything like that,
that makes it
impossible for you to work.
The U.S. government will give
you an income for life.
So, if you are permanently
paralyzed, you get
an income for life.
All three of these
are purchasable
in the private sector.
You can buy a pension.
You can buy survivors insurance
-- they don't call
it that, they call it
life insurance.
Just turning it around
to a different name.
The sellers of life insurance
don't want to remind you, that
you already have a life
insurance policy from the
government, because you
might say, well,
I got enough already.
So, they give it a different
name and they probably won't
remind you that you have it.
And then, you can buy disability
insurance.
But part of the problem with
private offering of these
insurances --
disability insurance, if it's
offered privately, suffers a
selection bias problem, that
some people, who realize that
they are going to have a
disability, will buy the
insurance right away.
And then, we have health
insurance.
And I don't want to use the
U.S. an example for this,
because we're kind
of a laggard on
most of these things.
But we had a new health bill
that passed under Obama last
year, and it's starting to gear
up, but the U.S. is not
the world leader in
health insurance.
It has currently about
40 million people
with no health insurance.
And then, there's workers
compensation.
These are the main aspects of
social insurance today.
Workers compensation is an older
form of health insurance
that preceded health insurance,
at least in the
United States.
And it compensated workers for
accidents that occurred at
work, and, in the U.S.,
this came in in
the progressive era.
But all these are risk
management devices that are
offered by governments.
Now, these social insurance
schemes are relatively recent
innovations, and, in fact,
I think, that the
first national --
I know that --
the first national social
insurance programs began in
Germany in the late
19th century.
So, another theme of this course
has been, that the
ability to do things like this
requires a developed society
with a certain technology,
with an information
technology, with a bureaucratic
technology.
And they haven't been around
for that long.
If you go back in history 200,
300 or more years, there
wasn't social insurance
anywhere.
Maybe there was, in some
isolated community, but
basically it didn't exist. And
so, the history of social
insurance is interesting,
and I think, it reflects
information technology growth.
The country that is most
remarkable for having invented
social insurance is Germany
under Otto von
Bismarck in the 1880s.
And I think, that it happened
there first because of the
information technology.
It's an interesting
story that --
there were various attempts to
start social insurance in
different parts of the
world, that were
half-hearted and failed.
In the United Kingdom in the
late 1700s, there was a town
called Speenhamland, a tiny town
in the U.K., that decided
they would start social
insurance.
They decided, that there was a
living wage that anyone ought
to be able to earn, and anyone,
who earned less than
that, would have the difference
paid by the town.
So, it's called the Speenhamland
Law, and that
town offered to pay
the difference.
The problem was,
it didn't work.
Too many people reported, that
they were getting less income
than the living income that
they defined, and the town
discovered it was being
ripped off.
The problem was, they couldn't
identify what a person's
income really was, accurately.
They couldn't tell, whether
someone was goofing off or
not, and so, they dropped it.
I think, there are other
examples of failed experiments
like this, but it took hold
first in Germany in the 1880s,
and they got accident insurance,
health insurance,
and old age insurance, or
retirement, for everyone in
Germany in the 1880s, and it
was considered a fiasco by
other countries of the world.
When Germany announced these
plans to create social
insurance, the London Times
wrote an article saying, this
whole thing will fall
through and fail.
The government is going to run
all of these insurance
policies for something like, I
think, there were 11 million
workers in Germany at the time,
and in London they said,
you've got to be kidding.
No government in the world
has ever managed to run
something like this.
Let's think particularly about
retirement insurance.
The German government set up a
plan, whereby people would
contribute over their working
lives to a social security
system, and the system would
then years later, 30, 40 years
later, keep a tab, about how
much they contributed, and
then pay them a pension for
the rest of their lives.
So, the Times wondered
aloud, are they going
to mess this up?
They've got to keep records
for 40 years.
They were talking about the
government keeping records,
and they thought, nobody can
really manage to do this, and
that it will collapse
in ruins.
But it didn't.
The Germans managed to do this
in the 1880s for the first
time, and actually it was
an idea that was copied
all over the world.
So, why is it that Germany was
able to do something like this
in the 1880s, when it was not
doable anywhere else?
It had never been done
until that time.
I think this has to do
ultimately with technology.
Technology, particularly
information technology, was
advancing rapidly in
the 19th century.
Not as rapidly as in the 20th,
but rapidly advancing.
So, what happened in Europe
that made it possible to
institute these radical
new ideas?
I just give a list
of some things.
Paper.
This is information
technology, but
you don't think --
in the 18th century, paper,
ordinary paper it was very
expensive, because it was made
from cloth in those days --
they didn't know how to make
paper from wood, and it had to
be hand-made.
As a result, if you bought a
newspaper in, say, 1790, it
would be just one page, and
it would be printed on the
smallest print, because it
was just so expensive.
It would cost you like
$20 in today's
prices to buy one newspaper.
Then, they invented the paper
machine that made it
mechanically, and they made it
out of wood pulp, and suddenly
the cost of paper went down.
By the way, I found an old
textbook from Yale
University from 1837.
It's still sitting there on
the shelf in the library.
I was looking --
we were using a Principles of
Economics textbook for all
Yale students, they all had
to take the same course.
And it is a nice little book,
but it was so small --
I picked it up --
it was like that big.
You could put in your pocket.
I think it's, because books were
just expensive, so the
students --
you have these huge textbooks
now, that weigh so much they
probably challenge
your back --
back then, you could
carry your books.
There was a fundamental economic
difference, and so,
paper was one of the things.
And you never got a receipt
for anything,
when you bought something.
You go to the store and
buy something, you
think you get a receipt?
Absolutely not, because it's
too -- well, they wouldn't
know why, but that's the
ultimate reason --
too expensive.
And so, they invented paper.
Two, carbon paper.
Do you people even know
what this is?
Anyone here heard
of carbon paper?
Maybe, I don't know.
It used to be, that, when you
wanted to make a copy of
something, you didn't have
any copying machines.
You would buy this special
paper, which was --
do you know what -- do I have
to explain this to you?
You know what carbon paper is?
You put it between two sheets of
paper, and you write on the
upper one, and it comes through
on the lower one.
This was never invented until
the 19th century.
Nobody had carbon paper.
You couldn't make copies
of anything.
There was no way
to make a copy.
They hadn't invented
photography, yet.
They had no way to
make a copy.
You had to just hand-copy
everything.
The first copying machine --
maybe I mentioned that -- didn't
come until the 20th
century, and they were
photographic.
And the typewriter.
That was invented
in the 1870s.
Now, it may seem like a small
thing, but it was a very
important thing, because you
could make accurate documents,
and they were not subject to
misinterpretation because of
sloppy handwriting --
and I'm doing sloppy handwriting
here for you, but
I'm using the old
technology here.
But the typewriter.
And you could also
make many copies.
You could make six copies at
once with carbon paper.
And they're all exactly
the same.
You can file each one in a
different filing cabinet.
Four, standardized forms. These
were forms that had
fill-in-the-blank with
a typewriter.
They had filing cabinets.
And finally, bureaucracy
developed.
They had management school.
Particularly in Germany, it was
famous for its management
schools and its business
schools.
Oh, I should add, also,
postal service.
If you wanted to mail a letter
in 1790, you'd have trouble,
and it would cost you a lot.
Most people in 1790 got maybe
one letter a year, or two
letters a year.
That was it.
But in the 19th century, they
started setting up post
offices all over the world,
and the Germans were
particularly good at this kind
of bureaucratic thing.
So, there were post offices in
every town, and the social
security system operated through
the post offices.
Because once you have post
offices in every town, you
would go to make your payments
on social security at the post
office, and they would give you
stamps, and you'd paste
them on a card, and that's
how you would show
that you had paid.
So, I think that this kind of
information technology brought
us the social security system.
And the kinds of advances in
information technology that
we've seen more recently will
eventually lead to changes in
the system.
Ultimately, technology drives
finance, and the system
responds to changes
in technology.
All right.
So, I just wanted
to just wrap up.
I talked today about a broader
social purpose that's served
by our finance, and it takes
place in terms of for-profit
as well as nonprofit.
But the distinction between
for-profit and nonprofit is a
subtle one.
I think, what happens is, people
think of a purpose of
something they want to achieve,
and then they think,
how can I use our financial
technology to incentivize
people to subscribe capital to
this project or to give their
personal attention
to this project?
And then, our system of finance
has a lot of things, a
lot of devices, that can allow
the providence of capital, and
that will incentivize people.
I think, another theme of this
course has been Behavioral
Finance that I think --
people are psychological, they
have emotions, and they react
in complicated ways.
One of the oldest themes of
economics is, that people
respond to incentives, but they
respond to pleas to their
morality as well, or their
ideals as well.
When we talk about the nonprofit
sector, it seems
that the financial arrangements
reflect a
combination of selfish
money-oriented incentives and
more social-purpose-incentives.
And the same thing goes with
government activities.
Anyway, I guess, I have one more
lecture, and I'm going to
talk next time more broadly
about, what finance offers us,
and how it allows us to achieve
social purposes.